[Music]
we have this sense that survival is like
hold on to your hat right here it comes
i don't think of it that way
[Music]
i'm a former air force seer instructor
which is survival evasion
resistance and escape who are the people
who teach our soldiers what to do if
they come down behind enemy lines and
they want to get back home again
[Music]
over my 30 years or so of teaching these
skills this is really the most
consolidated version i've done
and many of the skills you're going to
see me doing here i've never done
anywhere else on camera
the core of the class is going to
revolve around the five basic needs of a
survivor
signaling personal protection sustenance
navigation
and health we'll talk about what to do
before you leave on a trip
how you should be thinking about things
before you enter into the wilderness
then we're gonna make a survival kit day
hikes are the most dangerous because we
don't tend to take that much with us
what i put a survival kit can literally
make the difference between life and
death if i find myself stuck out there
for a longer period in a survival
situation we need to be able to think
rationally
and not panic the key way to do this is
simply make your exhales
longer than your inhales and when things
start to go wrong my number one priority
is to get out of here
so signaling needs to be a number one if
your mind was going through oh i need
water i'm gonna need a fire
those are all secondary we can go
typically about
30 days without food and on average
about three days without water
when i was a kid growing up i had some
abuse issues
and as i got older i would start to
sneak out of the house when i would have
nightmares and flashbacks
i didn't want to be in a house that
didn't feel safe to me i wanted to go
outside and i'd go climb a tree
that was my safe zone the wilderness is
so amazing to help us
be capable competent human beings what i
really want you understand is that the
wilderness is not out to get you
she's not this creature that's hovering
and just waiting for
opportunity to pounce so relax that
mindset and go out there and play and
learn these techniques
it'll open up a whole new world for you
i'm jessie krebs and this is my master
[Music]
class
[Music]
you